this is the street in west london where
uh richard was last seen
last monday night so nearly a full week
ago now
he lives on the street with his uh with
his parents they say
uh they told he told them that he was
popping out to see a friend but he never
came back and they haven't heard from
him since they told me this is
very out of character of him he's 19 he
lives at home with them
but because of his health they say they
are extremely concerned now for his
well-being he has sickle cell disease
which means
taking medication twice a day and having
a full blood transfusion
once a month which they say he goes to
hospital for but they say he left home
without any of his medication without
a wallet without his coat even so they
are extremely concerned for his
well-being
all they uh say he had with him was his
phone but that's been turned off since
10 p.m
last monday so as i say they haven't
heard uh from him
since and as you can probably imagine
they are absolutely beside themselves
with worry
all he said to me was mommy i'm going to
see my friend
and i trusted him because i had no doubt
automatically we have friends here on
the ground floor i thought he was going
there so i had no reason to ask for that
question
because of the relationship and we trust
we have
so it's my baby it's my treasure it's my
oxygen it's my crown
it's everything to me
yeah it's the reason why i live
and clearly it's a very distressing time
for uh his mother and his father richard
is
currently in his first year studying it
at oxford brooks university he hasn't
spent any of the
last year at the university though
because of the pandemic he's been
shielding as i say here and as a result
his parents fear his mental health has
deteriorated
he may have been suffering from
depression they told me but actually
fear he
was may have been groomed online and is
now they
believe being held against his will they
reported him
missing on wednesday so two days after
they last saw him but initially
they feel very strongly they were not
given the necessary support by the
police nor the necessary resources
in order to find him they say he was
initially deemed a low-risk case but
only recently was made
high-risk we haven't had any
confirmation or reaction to this from
the metropolitan police but for their
part in their latest press release on
this
they say they are becoming increasingly
concerned for richard's welfare
with chief inspector claire mccarthy
saying officers are working tireless
have been working tirelessly to locate
him using all investigative
opportunities so speaking to witnesses
and also trawling cctv she says
and they also appeal to anyone with any
information to come forward